jennifer lopez is putting her best foot
forward when it comes to moving on from
alex rodriguez
i have a lot of people that believe in
me last week the couple announced that
after a two-year engagement in four
years of dating
they decided to call it quits and now a
source tells e.t
jennifer has been doing her best to keep
her head up with her split with alex
saying quote she tried her hardest to
make the relationship work
but it just wasn't making her happy
anymore she knew it was time to let go
there were issues when it came to
wedding plans and trust issues that she
couldn't get past
it's crazy the source adds that their
families have also been affected by the
end of the relationship
her kids are sad about the breakup
because they all grew so close
but ultimately want what's best for
their mom and for her to be happy
there's still love and respect between
the two families of course
jen shares 13 year old twins emmy and
max with her ex
mark anthony while alex has two
daughters 16 year old natasha
and 12 year old ella from his ex-wife my
girls
adore jennifer she's she's a great role
model for me i'm the luckiest father in
the world to to be able to
you know expose my beautiful daughters
to someone as brilliant
as jennifer when announcing their split
last week j.lo and a-rod released a
statement writing quote
we have realized we are better as
friends and look forward to remaining so
we will continue to work together and
support each other on our shared
businesses and projects
he's so supportive he's such a
supportive person and he's
so lovely it seems like alex is grieving
the relationship in his own way after
posting this video a day before their
split
the source explains that jennifer has
been taking time to focus on herself
and surround herself with loved ones and
she's also committed to and focused on
work
currently shooting the movie shotgun
wedding in the dominican republic
in 2018 jayla revealed to et how she
balances it all
you know i have great partners nobody
does everything alone
you know even with the kids it takes a
village you know what i mean
um but i just have wonderful people in
my life i have a lot of loving people i
have a lot of people that believe in me
and believe in what we're doing together
and
what they know the kids come first and
then everything else kind of falls in
line after that and we just take it day
one day at a time